[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente la nouvelle
émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
g
fini pour moi
[Musique]
m
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir
coli berges heures pour double janvier
10 je suis votre cadeau de noël
je dois remercier monsieur hervé bourges
le président d'antenne 2 et qu'est ce
que je dois faire
ne vous inquiétez pas je m'occupe de
tout j'ai mis sur moi c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit est vrai ça ne veut pas être très
doux
bon jouer avec nous ce soir deux stars
de la variété française sa voix chaude
des hauts fourneaux et son air glaciers
des bas fonds ont fait d'elle la plus
grosse vendeuse de disques français à
l'étranger
elle nous aguiche lorraine patricia kaas
bassin
le dernier babaci les moutons voter il
serait président de la république mais
quand il gratte sa guitare sèche
il nous met les larmes aux yeux francis
cabrel
et ce soir une portugaise qui a raté
tous ces ménages pourtant pour elle les
burnes ne comptent pas pour des prunes
chanteuse actrice styliste elle a tous
les talents plus des talons aiguilles
voici votre cadeau de noël lio
[Musique]
je te connais pas toi mais oui tu me
connais alors lio est ce que tu es prête
on va faire une interview fin du monde
c'est encore une idée à 10 ans à 20 ans
bien alors c'est la fin du monde
tu peux sauver un livre lequel tu sauf
les belles endormies de kawabata parce
que c'est un livre érotique entre des
toutes jeunes filles est un très vieux
monsieur qu'il regarde dormir dans un
bordel japonais et c'est vraiment tendre
et c'est vraiment lent est bon et doux
et il ya la jeunesse et la vieillesse
ensemble et comme en attendant toujours
à séparer les deux je trouve ça un
niveau magnifique et si tu devais
choisir un héros local
corto maltese rock corto maltese oui
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
jamais laissé abattre
quand il a vu qu'il n'avait pas de ligne
de chance dans sa main ben ça qui s'en
est fait une au rasoir
je trouve qu'il faut toujours être au
rasoir dans la vie et si tu devais
emporté un journal aucun journal aucun
aucun aucun je trouve qu'il faudrait
tout recommencer à zéro parce que c'est
pas de l'info c'est de la désinformation
quelle voiture tu choisirais une
thunderbird bleu ciel comme y avait dans
american graffiti c'est ma préférée à
une émission de télé liot je garde pas
d'émissions télé je pense que je
regarderai même pas la télé un couture
et j'hésite entre azdine et la croix je
peux pas prendre les deux tu peux oui
l'aide
un monument je sais pas peut-être
peut-être la tour eiffel parce qu'elle
pointe haut vers le ciel et en même
temps elle à quatre pattes bien carré
par terre et puis quelle est belle quand
elle est éclairée ça fait comme de la
dentelle
où est la tour eiffel et une fleur lyon
un coquelicot
tu sais pourquoi parce que les
coquelicots
d'abord on peut pas les accueillir ça se
flétrit tout de suite
donc c'est vraiment une fleur accrochée
à la vie
que les pas prétentieuse et pourtant
elle est rouge sang en plus elles
poussent le long des chemins de fer et
les sauvages c'est une rebelle c'est une
fleur rebelle et fragile je laime cette
fleur chante plutôt clic on est un
gentil coquelicot messieurs et un astre
le soleil le soleil parce que c'est la
chaleur parce que c'est la vie parce que
sans soleil a pas de vie parce que c'est
rayonnant et parce que c'est l'amour et
moi je crois qu'on sache quoi quand
l'amour
sa valeur 1 c'est dur de faire des télés
là puisqu'ils étaient parties quand même
pour une grande campagne de promotion
c'est dur les télés oui c'est dur parce
qu'il n'ya pas de place mais pas de
place pour l'artiste alors on se
retrouve confronté à des problèmes de
choix qui est passé dans des émissions
qu'on ne défend pas avec lesquels on n'a
pas envie vraiment de collaborer pas ce
que j'appelle ça vraiment de la
collaboration
quand par exemple on passe à jean pierre
foucault sacre histoire et on se pose
des questions quand même non mais
écoutez c'est grave parce que c'est
parce que ça parle moi j'ai envie de
parler à ce public là j'ai envie que
qu'il me connaisse eu envie de lui
raconter des histoires mais de passer à
travers ce biais là c'est très déformant
donc c'est compliqué et en même temps
comme en existe autrement parce qu at il
tellement le choix
mais c'est vrai qu'un jour c'était au
début tu vas chez collaro et il te
demande de chanter c'est l'époque de
banana split de chanter banana split et
avec des mecs à lui en fait ça ne
faisait pas rire du tout il a forcé à le
faire non non ne m'a pas forcée j'ai
refusé je m'acquitte acheter une banane
à la fin quand même oui mais attend il
faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte
c'est vrai qu'il m'a jeté une banane
mais de toute façon c'est pas la banane
que j'ai reçues qui qui me pèse pas ce
que j'ai fait la chanson comme je
voulais finalement il voulait me mettre
autour de moi des sites utilisent des
culturistes enfin des gens de son équipe
habillé en champion olympique parce que
c'était un col haro sur sur le sport et
j'étais lui dire écoute moi j'en veux
pas parce que ma chanson c'est pas de la
kermesse et m'a regardé et m'a dit
mettez chanson c'est pas du claudel
judith a raison mais c'est ma chanson je
peux alors je pars ce long et il m'a
laissé faire comme je voulais mais à la
fin bond m'a lancé une banane et alors
c'est sa banane c'est vrai qu'au début
un jour tu allais voir le patron de la
maison de disques et tu refusais d'avoir
3 % du détail qui voulaient 5% et été
mis à pleurer dans son bureau il a
accepté finalement c'était un principe
j'ai refusé de signer à moins de ça
parce que pour moi c'était très clair
très bien j'avais 16 ans mais c'est bien
mais c'était ça ma force
si je te dis pour ça qu'on vient des
vieux conséquent le temps passe on sera
money il faut pas se ramollir j'avais
bien raison à 16 ans d'être comme
j'étais ce que je défende et des choses
bien tu t'es pas beaucoup évolué un
petit peu par moment un bon mais ses
finances alors on va faire une interview
première fois à faire ton premier
souvenir par exemple c'était comment je
me suis retrouvé à avoir un caniche au
lieu d'un mouton
comment j'avais été au marché qu'elle
était dans mon village à maywand et
j'étais tombé mais complètement
amoureuse d'un petit mouton tout blanc
mignon au jeu devait avoir quoi quatre
ans et je dis je veux le mouton je veux
le mouton et jetez la même époque mais
mignon et ma mère me dit écoute on va
rentrer à la maison et on reviendra tout
à l'heure le chercher parce que tu vois
je suis chargé tout ça et je fais bon
ben d'accord
sachant très bien elle que le marché
sont allés à 1h
elle me ramène à toi nous faire le
mouton tu vois il est parti membre
là je n'ai pas bougé je me suis jetée
par terre ça a été terrible il a fallu
aller chercher mes grands parents et mon
grand père a dit attends bien la maison
je te promets que je vais être amené
peut-être pas un montant mais quelque
chose qui ressemble il est allé le
chercher un caniche noir très belle
histoire
ton premier baiser dans la cage
d'ascenseur
parce que tu dis pas tu as dit que en
fait le coup de la langue tu avais vu
dans union parce que chez toi quand tu
étais petit il y avait des revues comme
ça qu'ils quittent rennais avait union
et puis avait des revues qui venait
dessus elle aussi a été vraiment gentil
couple à l'enjeu l'évident union si tu
savais ce que j'ai vu dans l'union et
dans d autres revenus business events y
avait chez vous
sur le coup de la loi et voilà les
chaussures nous partons c'est ça car il
y avait de tout absolument dans cette
vidéo c'était assez joli ça faisait des
compositions absolument c'était des
pages pleines tombe au père à l'époque
tu as vu en train de lire en cachette
ces revues qui l'a remarqué que l'église
est parce que je l'avais pas tout à fait
à la bonne place et ça c'est à dire en
fait tu n'as pas besoin de te cacher
pour lewis à nous emmerder
il m'en parle mais moi je disais oui je
sais je sais y'a pas de problème est en
fait lui avait pas trop vite et beaucoup
moins drôle si c'était permis non non
c'était pas ça c'était absolument pas ça
toute façon je le faisais redents dans
l'idée s'était permis moi j'ai jamais eu
le sentiment que c'était interdit
non c'était pas fait c'était que c'était
comme une intrusion dans mon intimité
oui érotique et affectueux même nom ne
peut pas dire on t'a dit tout c'était
tout a fondu qui se balader à poil à la
maison mais tout le monde se balader à
poil
les mannequins caennaise même le canis
la première expérience sexuelle
c'est à dire la chose c'est à dire la
chose sexuelle
ça veut dire quoi tu veux savoir par
exemple la première fois tu t'es fait
sauter ainsi annoncé qu'il est
absolument pas précis parce que dans à
la première fois que tu t'es fait
souhaiter je peux te dire mardi matin 11
mai la première fois dans ta vélib mardi
matin au genre ça répond à ta question
n'est pas précis ce tapis à présent et
demi en fait non je vais te dire ma
question je vais savoir si c'était ton
ton parolier duval ou ton compositeur
allen ski parce que je ne sais pas très
bien mais coutu leur demandera de
premières tv
c'était en belgique c'était une émission
de ça plaise quoi génération 80 avait le
trac
or vous savez vous m'y attends
maintenant ça va tu as pu le trac sigean
que j'avais encore le trac en fait ce
soir j'ai pas le trac
ton premier bilan le premier bide
finalement je sais pas c'est peut-être
quand j'ai signé mon premier contrat de
disque j'aurais peut-être dû réfléchir à
deux fois j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas je sais que mon premier beau guide
c'était quand j'étais enceinte
ton premier noël je m'en souviens pas un
particulier mais je me souviens bien de
la préparation autour de noël
alain goualch au portugal parce que on
aller avec mon grand père coupait un
sapin à la tombée de la nuit ils
disaient qu'ils braconnent et enfin je
suis même pas sûr ça fait peut-être dans
un terrain derrière shelly mais ça
participe est complètement l aventure
c'était bien et puis on aller cueillir
la mousse au pied des arbres pour en
tapisser la crèche et c'était bien tu
vas le principe de l'émission contre un
sujet sur lequel tu vas me dire si c'est
de l'info si c'est de l'intox
[Musique]
oh
du coup
lorsque les petits et les grands auront
une dernière fois admirer les vitrines
des grands magasins et qu'ils auront
enfin fait leur choix à vos voyages à
tapis une chaise lorsque nous vîmes
auront revêtu leurs habits de lumière et
que les pouvoirs publics auront accordé
les dernières autorisations
tout est fait pour aider perdre et il a
une autorisation exceptionnelle
perpétuel non révocable pour pouvoir
circuler dans le ciel sur terre partout
sans que personne ne puisse lui demander
de s'arrêter
c'est le seul qui autorisait à tout
enfin lorsque la 24e casse du calendrier
de l'avent sera ouverte et que les
dernières lettres lui seront parvenues
alors le père noël chaussera ses grandes
bottes enfilera ses gants ajustera sa
tunique de velours rouge bordée
d'hermine blanche et partira pour sa
longue tournée du 24 décembre
[Musique]
pas
et
sa précieuse note solidement arrimés
derrière lui il glissera silencieusement
à travers les plaines glacées de la peau
ni ses meilleurs rennes emporteront son
traîneau jusque dans nos contrées
[Musique]
alors
et quelques minutes après les douze
coups de minuit il descendra doucement
par la cheminée pour apporter ce que
chacun lui aura demandé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà le père noël va apporter des
cadeaux aux enfants sages
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox lio à
l'oreille ses meilleurs moments de
l'émission
non mais ce soir je peux pas alors
maintenant pour laisser à patricia
francis le temps de jouer pendant que
vous tapez sur votre minitel pour gagner
des cadeaux philips nous on va écouter
lions
jacomina dans paris
m
là
[Musique]
le
change on n'a pas de chance
tous les gens sont les mêmes
j'y peux
il ment
chez lui
trop tard
[Musique]
m
mtp un mensonge puisque je sais que vu
[Musique]
paris
non
comment
[Musique]
leclerc
rapporté des cadeaux aux enfants sages
est de l'info est de l'intox
patricia toi de jouer je pense que c'est
de l'info c'est de l'info je pense et
toi français deviennent fous
ouais c'est ce que dit on m'a dit aussi
ouais bah tu mords moi j'ai dit que
c'était de l'intox les 504 l'info bon
d'accord
alors philippe maintenant est ce de
l'info est de l'intox ouais c'est facile
c'est marqué partout dans la presse ça
se voit partout dans la rue c'est de
l'info on applaudit les candidats
le sport ça fait un partout
pour ce qui est du cadeau ne cherche
plus moi je vais prendre un petit bout
de sa clio unis où exactement
je suis né en guadeloupe au portugal
mais tu as vécu au mozambique ou non oui
pendant 14 mois c'est les souvenirs de
sa non pas du tout des photos souvent
alors l'époque le mozambique était une
colonie portugaise
ton père fernando de vasconcelos était
militaire là-bas
et puis ta mère jour n'a eu marre de la
de la brousse elle l'a laissé
elle est rentrée au portugal pourquoi en
parler comme ça elle en a pas humain
d'où la boue c'était vraiment un climat
difficile c'était la guerre des colonies
se passer des choses vraiment affreux
dont mozambique en angola on torturait
c'était vraiment du fascisme c'était
sous salazar et ma mère était marié à
cet homme qu'elle aimait et c'est vrai
que ça se passait pas bien pour ce pur
elle là bas parce qu'elle voyait des
choses qui la révolte est humainement
terriblement et lui il était sergent
dans l'armée il y participer donc ça
plus plus le fait que ce soit
effectivement un macho mais qui n'est
pas match au portugal c'est vraiment dur
à trouver
alors ensuite elle est revenue au
portugal elle a rencontré un homme qui
s'appelait le berthod quitté insoumis
lui qui pouvait pas faire la guerre des
colonies voilà son parti en vue
d'arrêter ses études
oui elle est partie en belgique et quand
est arrivé en belgique c'était très dur
pour elle ça a été dur pour elle et pour
alberto beaucoup fretey ça a été dur
pour moi aussi mais je pense plus dur
pour eux beaucoup plus durs pour
beaucoup protégé
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait au début quand
sont arrivés là-bas pauvres 1 tous les
métiers que font les immigrants il est
plongeur femme de ménage serveuse
oui ça a été dur pendant effectivement
pendant deux ans on a vécu dans la
clandestinité vous c'est quoi le pire
souvenir de cette époque là le pire
souvenir de cette époque c'était que ma
mère travailler la nuit et que je ne
supportait pas d'être séparé d'elle et
donc jeu mais je m'en fichais de chez
moi pour aller la retrouver
elle son restaurant c'était facile parce
que les toilettes étaient à l'entresol
tu vas me disait je vais aller faire
pipi
j'ai déjà ma chance je prenais mon
manteau et zouk je filais je pourrais
dans toutes les rues et puis je me
mettais à la porte du restaurant et puis
ma mère servait de l'autre côté
et de temps en temps je la voyais faire
il venait me chercher permettent à une
table et puis pro minutes après
l'ouverture arrivions pourquoi elle a
disparu elle est laissée en eau
ben voila je jouais aux cow-boys et aux
indiens ce thème
c'était la vie c'est un peu la valise en
carton qua non pas du tout
m
la valise en carton sa mère mais non ici
c'est sa mère linda de suza et la mère
de ne-yo ou saviez pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc va reprendre le
spectacle de sa mère la valise en carton
vous aurez le voir c'est pas sa mère
vous insultez portugais mais la
chanteuse portugaise je suis portugaise
alors j'avais un traitement quelque
chose à 30 me contre a demandé puis la
toile sa mère qu'elle sa mère donnant sa
mère donna summer
sa mère raconte le spectacle de savères
la valise en carton besoin de voir
vu que c'est une bande de gaza doit
avoir du poil aux pattes c'est très bien
géré la voir parce que moi aussi j'en ai
pouvoir bel âge en épi parce que je suis
pile et vous adorez sa mère linda de
suza elle a maigri de 5 kg une journée
annonce agi d'insérer absolue basée sous
les bois une mauvaise blague dans la rue
personne n'y croit finalement tu vois
personne ne veut pas arrêter la fille de
linda de suza non écoute
franchement je peux le dire parce que il
faut dire les choses quand on les pense
très fort
je trouve que il ya on peut parler des
choses qui sont des vrais souvenirs de
vie et qu'on a plaisir à partager
et il ya autre chose ou qui est de les
utiliser à but mercantile
donc ces deux positions et que c'est
très important et et puis voilà et puis
linda trouve a fait un choix moi je fais
un autre choix et je préfère le mien que
si dix mois c'est à cause de ces années
difficiles que tu as quand même toujours
fait assez bien attention à tes affaires
quelle affaire faire d'argent on peut
toujours faire attention à ces non j'ai
pas fait attention aux affaires d'argent
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas d'argent je
te débattent et les actions de la
compagnie électrique belge que tu avais
acheté à l'époque parce que j'en ai fait
souvent doute plus longtemps et plus a
pas gardé et la maison hangar tulard
devant lui aussi la fin tu la vends ma
roue mais alors en quoi ça t'intéresse
c'est pourquoi voir
la maison de l'image 3dans trois
secondes on peut faire affaire tapie
c'est comme ça et ce public on n'est pas
riche dirigerait je mens pas réellement
bon dis moi mais tu fais de la pub quand
même là tu tu gagnes de l'argent donc on
va les noms des pubs moi je sais pas je
t'ai vu dans des pubs pour magie pour le
bus on écoute ça fait combien d'années
on n'était pas à la page 14
la pâte à tarte ya passante en bas de la
patate tu te portes de la patate heures
par mois de l'année parlons-en
scènes de ménage sur le canapé alors là
patatras alors là tu as ta soeur qui est
effectivement ça t'a bien apporter la
masse attendait un trou de souris mais
attention je sais que beaucoup de sous
quand même savoir qu'ils allaient gifle
la savak youtube tu vas voilà c'est ça
le rend pas moins au portugal
machisme excusez moi bon on continue on
repasse à la belgique ta mère vit
toujours en belgique
tu vas t'en longtemps est ce que tu te
sens le plus française portugaise belge
européenne ou terrienne railleu d'urcel
la terrienne terrienne bien sûr puisque
j'ai les deux pieds dessus
enfin les femmes c'est être un monde
c'est vraiment ça mais c'est bien pour
ça que j'aime ce sont à mon dossier j'ai
jamais dit ça c'est que tu veux pas te
croit au père de famille on écoute ce
n'est pas une question de père de
famille je ne m'attaque tenez vous bien
c'est au dehors tp alors faire un petit
bout tout belge je vais te dire des noms
de gens belge et tu vas me dire comme ça
ce que tu en penses
beaudoin le roi baudoin écoute ce type
est pas si mal moi je sais très bien
dans un pays comme la belgique où il ya
vraiment un vrai un vrai racisme est une
vraie tendance au fascisme quand même un
extrême droite dans toute son horreur
c'est un type qui tous les ans à la noël
quand il vient faire son speech et bien
il parle des timides les ans les en les
intégrant en les faisant faire partie du
pays et je trouve que c'est pas mal
en ces temps qui courent ya peu de gens
qui prennent ces dispositions
fabiola on a l'air bien trop de gens
pensent je sais pas mais moi non plus
oui alors une autre belge que christine
ockrent
je préfère raymond devos ouais jacques
brel j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup je
trouve qu'il ya des chansons si tu les
connais les chansons de jacques brel
sens comment on la calcule le chantier
qu'est ce que je pourrais être champion
le pays et non pas ça va je pourrais
être chanté la plus connue ne me quitte
pas on peut oublier tout peut s'oublier
ça suffit déjà oublié le temps des
malentendus et le temps perdu à savoir
comment oublier ceux qui tuaient parfois
à coude pourquoi google du bonheur ne me
quitte pas elle ne quitte pas un vain
mot
on va voir un petit sujet sur la
belgique tu me diras suis bien placé
pour dire si c'est de la poésie c'est de
l'intox la grande folie a duré neuf mois
neuf mois pendant lesquels le moindre
coup de pioche la moindre grue la
moindre ben était devenu suspect tout le
peuple belge était en alerte
le responsable le voici jean-claude des
fossés journaliste très sérieux de la
télévision belge
il fit un jour un reportage sur de
grands travaux inutiles comme ses deux
ponts en pleine forêt l'effet fut
prodigieux de toute la belgique des
lettres lui parvint pour dénoncer
d'autres merveilles ici une autoroute
qui meurt en plein champ là bas un petit
pont man show dans la nature
l'ami jean claude sont à la voir de près
ces chefs-d'oeuvre une émission était né
le journal des grands travaux inutiles
devenu bientôt le quart d'heure le plus
regardé de la télévision belge
un thème inépuisable pour la plus grande
joie du journaliste moi je veux
quelqu'un qui adore la solitude alors
pouvoir dans son métier se retrouver
tout seul sur une gigantesque autoroute
de 6 km l avoir rien que pour soi ou
dans un hôpital vide de 12 étages c'est
extraordinaire on a une impression comme
ça de je ne sais pas de grandeur de
d'aisance qui va beaucoup plus
mais les bonnes choses ont une fin après
neuf mois l'émission c'est ça son auteur
s'était lassé mais l'expression grands
travaux inutiles gti été lancé de temps
en temps en s'échangeant des ans tiens
j'ai découvert un gti donc un grand
travail inutile même si c'est un petit
travail dit il
et donc il ya une sorte de comment
dirais-je de conscience dans
l'administration d'éviter des gti et de
dire attention si on présente ce si ça
risque de devenir un gti
je vous invite à faire la même chose en
france d'ailleurs je suis sûr qu'en
cherchant un peu vous trouverez
également des gti à travers tout
l'hexagone
[Musique]
une émission une émulsion sur les grands
travaux inutiles en belgique s de
l'impôt est de l'intox
lio à l'oreille ses meilleurs moments de
l'émission au nom il fait ce soir je
peux pas
c'est mme gareau cette fois tu es à tous
écrit tout composer tout produit et
était devenu grand mon garçon presque
j'ai pris quelques cours de guitare
ouais j'ai eu du temps là je me suis
arrêté pour mon tour deux ans ouais 12
ans tu appris le métier quoi il était
temps qu'on y donne pas deux ans
d'absence tu prends des risques quand
même un certain risque mais sous que
c'est encore plus risqué d'enchaîner les
disques
comme ça la mitraillette sans avoir ni
l'envi le faire parce que j'avais pas
envie de faire ni l'avoir le
l'inspiration c'est la base de tout à
partir mans on a cette matière qui
inspiration espèce de petite bombe qu'on
a à l'intérieur de soi je pense que l'on
peut se cacher et tu le trouves comment
le paysage musical français
après deux ans d'absence sir j'ai
beaucoup bougé
donc c'est vraiment ce qui se passe en
france seconde yann ya bruel mais si la
génération hamburger ya murat le
chouchou de la presse intellos qui est
un peu coincé entre les deux j'ai enfin
je veux dire que sans vendre ou sens en
vendre autant que bruel ou sans avoir eu
une
une connotation comme ça très
spécifiques comme nu rage j'ai mon
espace c'est ça qui m'intéresse argent
forte avec des mots pas très gentil pour
lui le foot j'adore son vrai nom était
dit que c'était un vieux beau et c'est
dans la soirée de ce qui marche
non on peut là devrait aussi revoir pas
du tout c'est une mauvaise
interprétation ce que je peux te dire là
ce qui va passer à la télé par exemple
c'est d'accord j'assume complètement
une interview écrite et réécrit des
journalistes il est bien chez enfin
phrase extraite comme ça d'un d'une
discussion n'a plus n'a plus la même
valeur
quand elle est tronquée comme ça j'adore
chamfort j'adore ce mec est vraiment je
trouve sa fin je les appelais de l'a41
retard parce que je me retrouvais que h
dans le dos oui c'est un moment mais
c'est ça tu es là non plus sinon non
plus si j'avais si j'avais à dire des
choses pas gentil serait surtout pas sur
chamfort vraiment jeu des choses que je
n'ai que j'ai dit n'était pas du tout en
ces termes et vanessa parce que tu as
dit que contrairement à ce que toute la
presse pensé c'était pas la nouvelle
bébé tu l'a appelé pour garder les
alouettes se fait passer pour quelqu'un
qui peut alors s est ouverte à qui
balancent quelle femme karen avis dans
une esprit choc de consensus mou tout le
monde est d'accord avec tout le monde
c'est bien d'avoir des gens qui ont des
amis mais c'est vrai que pour moi c'est
pas la nouvelle bardou ouais voilà c'est
tout ouais et avec lio commencé ces
passionnés alors avec tous les coups
mais non c'est pas les camps moi j'aime
beaucoup ce disque parce qu'il ya plein
de chansons superbe vraiment les gens
sont passés à côté ils ont parfaitement
droit
mais sauf que c'était un album qui était
bien et parce que tu disais qu'elle est
un peu occupé un filon message je sais
c'est vraiment de faire le savez je veux
dire elle travaille beaucoup puisqu'elle
cumule de carrière on a eu des
différends dont on a parlé ensemble
c'est un peu d'accuser l'anglais c'est
un peu de la cuisine interne mais bon
c'est quelqu'un façon c'est on est de la
même famille pas
etienne daho une émission sur les grands
travaux inutiles en belgique s de l'info
est de l'intox
francis à toi de jouer je pense que
c'est de l'intox
tu penses que c'est de l'intox pour tous
est une histoire belge surtout pas une
histoire belge parce que j'admire
beaucoup les belges eux mais ça ne tient
qu'à nous aussi et toi je m'en fous de
l'info et toi alors finalement l'info de
l'intox mais non c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai plan fin des contrats vo dinh
utilisable par tous y at il une émission
sur les grands travaux inutiles en
belgique
non on va voir on va écouter notre
expert philippe gallard terraube en
europe maintenant je peux pas dire on
paye pour qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je
fasse là que tu nous dis si c'est de la
peau de l'intox cette histoire bah
voyons pas voyons c'est de l'info
[Applaudissements]
et ça sort d'où cette histoire pas les
petites boules ouais les gros travaux
inutiles
ouais eh bien ça sort de belgique
d'ailleurs à ce propos j'ai deux
remarques à vous faire
la première c'est que les grands travaux
n'ont pas été inutiles pour tout le
monde puisque ils ont permis aux belges
de rire pendant neuf mois et la deuxième
concerne tf1 où cet été à un producteur
inventif il faut le dire inventif a eu
l'idée de reprendre cette excellente
idée gratuitement d'ailleurs il avait
simplement oublié que pour faire des
grands travaux inutiles il faut des
entrepreneurs et que sur tf1 c'est
bouygues
bravo philippe bielle et laurent ça fait
2 1 pour patricia kaas grand père était
médecin je l'aimé beaucoup et il était
médecin dans votre villa à mon voyage et
il avait une clinique a été comment ça
que c'était un grand carré blanc parce
qu'il était très bon et qu'un médecin
est assez peu doué comme archives mais
voulait faire les deux villes tout faire
de toute façon j'aime y apprendre le
russe s'était c'était vraiment quelqu'un
de bien mais beaucoup d'influencé sur
toi je suppose en tout cas nous touche
encore beaucoup au plan politique aussi
parce qu'il était marxiste non oui il
était communiste mais c'est très sain
d'être communistes dans un pays fasciste
et à 12 ans tu t'es retrouvé finalement
être extrémiste de gauche ça dure et
qu'en même temps que ça dure toujours
ouais tu croyais en quoi exactement
j'avais la révolte pas là et aujourd'hui
que le communisme s'est effondré sous
quelle forme cette révolte de s'exprimer
at on a dit ça a été des choses qui
étaient certainement magnifique dans
l'idée ça a été extrêmement mal
appliquée parce que parce que c'est
comme les 68 c'est bien au moment ça
c'est puis après après comment comment
maintenir une flamme qui est juste en la
structure ans comment ne pas tuer sept
flamands la structure ans c'est vraiment
très très difficile et c'est vrai qu'on
a appris que d'être trop trop rigide ça
elles risquaient d'étouffer la flamme et
qu'il fallait toujours resté dans la
tente du monde et vivre vivre quand même
vivre c'est quand même bouger chaque
jour un petit pauvre au fur et à mesure
des connaissances et passe ce s'amarrer
une fois pour toutes à un discours
extrêmement établit toujours cherché
cherché plus loin c'est certainement ce
qu'on doit en tirer mais que les
révoltes d'initiales sont toujours de
mise
eh ben je pense que rien ne sort mais
j'en sais rien mon vieux je fais pas de
la politique moi moi je suis une artiste
moi je dit que il faut exploser les
choses c'est vrai que chez toi on
écoutait beaucoup de brel et brassens et
que l'europe était considéré comme
fasciste non pas fasciste capitaliste
capitale
bah oui mon père me disait que j'étais
une individuelle individualiste
romantique occidental tu as déclaré que
tu étais une déçus du socialisme depuis
la sphère greenpeace enfin oui
certainement ça a été quand même quelque
chose de
da c'est terrible pour moi parce que je
me disais bon voilà au moins ils vont
pas mentir
ils ont fait une énormité mais ils vont
venir le dire voilà on est victime ou
même de tout ça et ben non alors ça ça
m'a fait signer au club et ce thème plus
tentant que j'ai pensé à l'époque où il
ya eu l'appel pour que on vote
tonton je me disais que qu'il fallait
faire ça parce que parce que c'était
grave que chirac passe quand il y avait
le pen derrière parce que même si chirac
est certainement pas tout à fait la même
chose que le pen je dire il ya quand
même des passes pas dans son entourage
qui n'en sont pas très éloigné puis à
valéry giscard d'estaing à ça on sait
tous que c'est donc tout ça a été pour
moi dangereux et bon ben voila mais je
suis pas contente
non je trouve que c'est que c'est
terrible de se positionner comme il le
fait tu connais le prix d'un big mac
d'un big man non parce que je vais pas
chez mado je vais je vais chez quick
filaire ou 18 francs 40 18 francs 80 je
crois le big bill todd alors maintenant
ils ont des maxi frites puis pas très
longtemps avant qu avec des contres et
et moi je prends toujours mes années
c'est quelque chose parce que c'est bon
mais l'enjeu c'est qu'on se sert des big
mac maintenant pour calculer le niveau
de vie des gens dans les grandes villes
du monde
un bon 28 ans il est tombé bien bas
niemba la regarde bien c'est de la
fausse et c'est de l'intox
et oui madame regardez bien vous avez
entre les mains un tout nouvel index
économique
mika gbagbo
qui mesurent quoi j'ai pas la boulimie
environnantes
par exemple dernier né des indices
économiques à l'image du maître étalon
voici le hamburger le plus célèbre du
monde le big mac c'est la très sérieuse
union des banques suisses qui a décidé
de calculer le pouvoir d'achat dans 30
villes différentes à partir du temps de
travail nécessaire pour s'acheter un big
mac
un indice basé sur le big mat c'est
fantastique c'est fantastique pourquoi
parce que le big man dans le monde
entier ces deux tranches de pain de la
viande hachée soupoudré d'un petit peu
de pickles d'aromates de sauce tomate et
au moins là tout le monde a la même
référence chez mcdonald's france on se
refuse à tout commentaire
peut-être parce que paris n'est pas si
bien placé à paris il faut 39 minutes de
temps effectif pour acheter un big mat
alors que il en faut simplement 18 à
chicago à signer mais malheureusement il
en faut quatre heures à mixer au mexique
et à bombay ce qui donne quand même une
vue très nette sur les disparités des
pouvoirs d'achat de tel ou tel pays
ça fait combien rien n'a pour
d'enfants
femme de ménage gagne à peu près 45
fondeur une demi heure quand même
beaucoup pour une chose aussi mauvaise
pour digérer où il faut bien une bonne
journée de travail
quant aux moscovites il leur faut deux
jours de travail pour déguster le
dernier index économie capitaliste mais
l'étude a oublié d'ajouter les longues
heures de queue utilisé pour comparer
les niveaux de vie dans le monde et ce
de l'info s de l'intox lit ou à
l'oreille il fait ce soir je peux pas
maintenant c'est à vous de réfléchir à
vous chez vous 2 caps et sur votre
minitel et pendant ce temps on écoute de
la part de gilbert pour par son galant
jefferies
[Musique]
par ce rappel
genève tous les styles
que l' ami
oui les deux maires à wasquehal
[Musique]
mexique et
amis
[Musique]
oui
en bis
il
planes et calais
non
et le maroc
ouellet
mais c'est mal
aux manettes
m
d'accord
mais m
à
manqué
[Musique]
et
comparer les niveaux de vie dans le
monde s de l'info est de l'intox
patricia toi tu jouais alors intox
je crois pas une seconde pourquoi ça me
paraît ridicule
ouais enfin surtout dans des banques
suisses à tour de vis sont ridicules et
toi tant que ceux-ci intox aussi là je
peux le dire maintenant lio pour toi oui
qu'est ce qui te dire ça je sais pas moi
ça me semble tout à fait bien et bêtes
en même temps bon donc c'est comme l
info comme ce convoi journal télévisé
donc voilà c'est dit eh ben on va voir
philippe dire hein on écoute l'expert
noël mais c'est plutôt de manger un big
mac qui vous prêts risqués l'intox parce
que c'était de l'info on applaudit
commentaire à faire malgré ce qui
devient dans la bouche oui thierry j'ai
un commentaire à faire l'indicé big mac
existe bien al'inverse des indices cac
40 ni cailloux dow jones qui eux
indiquent plutôt le niveau de vie des
riches
l'indicé big mac indique plutôt lui le
niveau de vie des pauvres
on s'en fout du score nice on sait noël
dieu est amour
bon ça fait 2 1 pour théâtre pour être
franc je t'appelle liés aux vents bat
mais là tu as un terrain matériaux
d'accord mais en fait peut-être même pas
vraiment parce que c'est peut-être wanda
qui traitent pas je crois que c'est même
plutôt en bas qui trippent dis-moi banda
c'est vrai que tu as refusé de faire
l'été meurtrier parce que quand tu es
allé voir becker qui lui a dit que le
scénar était moins bien que le roman
c'est drôle moi oui enfin c'est drôle
mais j'avais un fiancé qui n'avait pas
envie de tourner mais que tu tournes ce
film que tourne en général on m'avait
dit ce film là mais en fait ça s'est
avéré que c'était quand même plutôt en
général quoi tu fais que des films avec
des femmes avec breillat avec akerman
avec kurys comment ça se fait des femmes
intello c'est quelque chose à se faire
pardonner
et pourquoi tu dis à me faire pardonner
que tu crois que peu d intellectuels que
les femmes intellectuelles ne baisse pas
bien informées un bon magazine
tous les clichés genre comme ça j'ai
rien à me faire pardonner ses des femmes
vraiment bien que les pages jaunes
non non ce n'est pas une question de ça
c'est la manière dont il a dit fait ma
vie nos sens j'aimerais pas faire des
comédies mais si j'étais mais oui mais
moi je suis vachement drôle c'est les
comédies françaises qui ne sont pas
c'est bien pour ça c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est parce qu'il a les tribus
splendide tous à laver les ex du
splendid des choses comme ça tu serait
formidable maintenant toi oui j'aimerais
plutôt faire des comédies comme comme
recherche susan désespérément comme un
poisson nommé wanda à tien an men sam
key bien et le père noël est une ordure
que thomas j'adore ce film mais je
connais même plein plein dialogue parker
avec ma soeur c'est toujours ce qu'on se
repasse quand on a le cafard 20 films
cultes on avait plus de 20 fois c'est
génial ça tombe bien
et pas une petite pièce madame c'est
pour boire un coup de rouge mon pauvre
ami yvert n'auriez pas une petite pièce
pour pistolet semi pour picorer division
one s'en prend avec la langue
heures avec ma soeur c'est 200 francs
c'est peu cher ami
100 francs de bijoux quand elle s'en
prend aux visions avec la langue et ben
non
53e sur la langue mais ça va pas la tête
bisous madame quand noël c'est 100
francs avec la langue
cet emprunt sur la langue dit
fondamentaux du jeu bratanov ces cadeaux
n'auriez pas une petite pièce et pour
boire un coup bisous et câlins des
déchets un pur pas coupé pour le
réveillon de quoi d'ailleurs sinon hanoï
où les du shit madame alter noël est une
ordure si je comprends bien vous dirai
d'abord leur gazon pour noël voilà que
des soirées par tous pour le réveillon
oui on y va d'accord chez moi dans la
camionnette camionnette
tu viens bien et enregistrent un petit
coup c'est noël
après teddy merci papa noël du shit de
l'herbe et des soirées pour le réveillon
ça vous tente
mais justement j'attendais que ça bon
d'accord vous serre la trêve de fait une
petite cape vous mettez votre cul dans
la cheminée et j'arrive à minuit pile on
gérait de dire un petit mot clé pour
noël faire l'amour avec le père noël
ouais ouais en costume ou est ce bon on
va vous allez avoir un orgasme terrible
un orgasme pour noël
mais tous les jours pour noël un superbe
raid vrai bon we wish it jeu m'avait
déjà demande donc c'est pour des
chavannes saison mardi à la quasi autant
on s'était une autre version du père
noël est une ordure s'est usée par
laurent bête il est drôle ce beau fils
se trouve pas oui dix mois les eaux ou
vendent à la première fois que je
l'interviewais tu m'as dit qu'est ce que
tu aimais pas chez toi c'est que tu
avais une trop grande bouche
est-ce que tu as changé d'avis ouais tu
l'aies me dire maintenant tu t'y
habituer newey adda match mais il est
tard et était petit à l'époque c'est
pour sa tvq
non mais tu vois ça en feront des cas
qu'on de l'avant parce que ça tu te dis
aussi de ne pas avoir assez de saint
aubin c'est fini je vais qu'est ce que
tu as fait un bond ou un peu plus mais
j'en ai passé plus tu vois un peu plus
qu'à l'époque tu trouve presque parce
qu'on s'occupe bien d'eux
tu as dit c'est chouette d'avoir les
mêmes fantasmes que son partenaire tu as
des fantasmes donne parce qu'en plus les
paroliers qui travaille pour toi sont
souvent des hommes c'est des fantasmes
donne c'est bien pour tous les deux
ouais ouais je suis d'accord voilà et
dans une autre interview je t'avais
demandé ce qu'il faisait le plus dans la
vie tu m'a dit écoute tu auras pas faire
de philosophie baiser c'est toujours à
jamais rassure alors on va faire une
courte interview oui non quand tu aimes
répondent par oui ou par non
est-ce que tu répondes site été surprise
avec une fille de joie quand tu vas au
hammam
non tu réparant tu peux te répondre est
ce que tu es prête à tout faire si tu
aimes oui est-ce que tu serais prête à
faire un film porno si c'était un grand
réalisateur bien sûr par franck darcel
mais si peu je serais d'accord oui non
truc très porno mais signé d'un grand
nombre
j'aime pas ta question n'ont pas signé
parce que signé d'un grand nom s'en fout
si c'est un merde mais si c'est un choix
de films porno comme par exemple empire
des sens je signe d'accord donc c'est
oui ben oui mais posé comme je lui ai
dit d'accord chéri e
on va s'arrêter à cause du csa qui passe
à des questions plus soft qu'est ce que
c'est qu'ils te fais rougis au jour
d'aujourd'hui qui pourraient de faire
rougir
moi je vais oser en a mais toi qu'est-ce
qui te ferait aux ya quelque chose de
bon c'est pas moi
turgis des fois ah oui je pique des
phares tout le temps aventure dans la
rue je te jure dans cet émirat cas on va
regarder parce qu'un produit qui empêche
les gens de rougir tu vas voir c'est pas
bien il est timide et il se soigne 10
jours par mois alexis avale une dose de
d'estimé donne un nouveau médicament
destiné à empêcher les timides de rougis
à l'origine je pensais qu'il fallait
dire avec toujours j'ai vu des médecins
au début qui montrent pas forcément
beaucoup aidé et puis j'ai trouvé cette
solution qui nous convient bien
ça va vraiment beaucoup mieux tu as
vraiment beaucoup mieux bon ça
traitement un traitement régulier mais
on peut on peut prendre ce médicament
avant un événement où justement fin qui
autrefois aurait généré un phare table
et j'avoue que ça m'aide beaucoup
après dix années de recherche des
laboratoires dulcie et pierre
pharmaceutique commercialise ce précieux
remettent depuis le mois dernier
si certains traitements combattent déjà
le stress c'est la première fois qu'un
médicament s'attaque directement aux
symptômes visibles de la timidité
le team à deurle provient de la mare en
tenue savard depuis sept ans un arbre
qui pousse en chine grâce à un certain
nombre de modifications chimiques
nous avons pu mettre au point des teams
adle qui possèdent des propriétés très
particulière au niveau des terminaisons
nerveuses qui elle même jeu sur les
vaisseaux qui règle le visage principal
marché du dating à dole les candidats
amoureux pour les professionnels du
mariage le rougissement est l'une des
causes principales des rencontres
avorter la personne qui n'arrête pas de
rejet va s'en tiennent à lui même
tellement mal que ça va la bloquer
prenez pas pour entreprennent importe
quelle relation avec quelqu'un d'autre
ça va faire peur à l'autre personne
enfin ceux ci restent les irréductibles
ceux qui sont trop timides pour
consulter un médecin ou entrer dans une
pharmacie
ce qui à force de jouer de leur timidité
en ont parfois fait une histoire de
charme
j'ai une espèce de tendresse et un peu
pour la timidité c'est mieux d'essayer
de la vente quoi je crois que c'est un
effort à faire d'eux de l'intérieur de
la tête mais je pense que ça rendra
service à beaucoup de gens parce qu'il
ya des gens qui sont un degré ou ou un
pas en avant devient dès fois difficile
alors ça sera un petit début de
traitement parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de manifestations un médicament
pour notre bureau giresse de l'info est
de l'intox
lio à l'oreille
j'ai complètement maintenant c'est à
vous de réfléchir pendant que vous tapez
sur votre minitel pour gagner des
cadeaux philips nous on va écouter la
fille à qui lie au poser des questions
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
tu comprends
moi je
[Musique]
g
il
autre chose
m
monsieur
[Musique]
j'y crois je me suis
m
je
son jeu
[Musique]
je
une autre
et
l'info est de l'intox francis à toi de
jouer je pense que si event auxon qui
croient pas toi c'est un peu contre
nature
bon ben on arrive à tout maintenant
pourriez bien sûr oui en fait ils
croient pas vienne mais rougir des
fouets et toi non plus tu crois pas toi
tu y crois pas toi par contre tu y crois
moi je veux tu croyais et ont
complètement
bon bah écoute on va tester son
discernement
philippe guérin oui oui bon bah on après
j'en abrège c'est de l'intox aller vite
vite on se dépêche on applaudit au
continuo finir il est ce que tu as un
commentaire à faire avant de mériter
non mais tu rigoles ou quoi thierry tu
as vu quel jour on est c'est peut-être
toi qui va les faire les courses du
réveillon en toi qui va taper les
embouteillages te bagarrer pour avoir un
caddie non mais enfin tu rigoles et se
taper là que pour les caisses c'est toi
qui va taper les deux du ps un bon alors
soit correct ben fiquet le score le
score c'est 3-2 pour patricia kaas
tu viens de gagner le match tu prends
ton petit téléviseur
tu regardes les cadeaux philips qui vont
défiler tu me dis celui que tu veux
[Musique]
tandis qu'au moment le discoverer tu
veux le téléviseur philips discoverer
multistandard pal secam affichage sur
écran autostore bravo en tableau 10 cd
c'est un plaisir avignon comment la
tapping elle va bien est ce qu'elle va à
l'école parce que tu m'avais dit qu'il
voulait jamais l'envoyer à l'école
elle va y aller tu as aidé et là dessus
j'ai passé des là dessus c'est que entre
peut-être entre deux mots j'ai choisi le
moindre mais quelle école je choisis
pour la petite une école du quartier
alors tous les mélanges de toutes les
races y est est ce que tu vas faire
baptiser parce que la dernière fois et
est toujours pas baptisé non elle n'est
pas baptisé n'est pas baptisé sexuelle
vers le banc d'en faire ben c'est
peut-être plus marrant voilà une bonne
réponse sur tout et jamais qu'on fait
c'est toi non tu veux commencer avec moi
ce soir je sais pas si c'est marrant
tepa en soutane et rien pour ne jamais
chercher à laurent gerra
[Musique]
lio est ce que tu es favorables à
l'avortement
moi je me suis fait avorter plein de
fois j'ai eu un enfant je sais pas si je
me ferait avorter encore avec la même
facilité 10 en mai mais je trouve que
c'est un droit inaltérable la peine de
mort
je suis contre je suis contre à 400
mille pour cent quand une société aura
prouvé qu'elle a le bien fondé de juger
on vous parlera des choses d'ailleurs ce
jour là il y aura plus de peine de mort
parce que rapide des lignes si grave
pour ça est ce que tu es pour la
légalisation des drogues douces
oui je suis pour la légalisation et
l'information de tout ce qui vous fait
du bien
quels sont tes tabou j'ai pas tabou
[Musique]
je dis une fois que tes héros préférés
étaient jésus-christ et pénélope est ce
que pour jésus-christ tu peux nous
expliquer mais c'est très c'est très
évident à comprendre c'était un vrai
révolutionnaire jésus-christ jeudi en
fait le vrai martyr c'est judas parce
que jésus la halle beau rôle et judas
lui il est finalement jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours
il a le mauvais rôle c'est lui le vrai
martyr mais oui on peut très bien voir
ça comme ça ce qui prouve encore qu'il
n'y a pas d'ombré s'il n'y a pas de
lumière et qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans
la mort bien entendu que judas était
quand même la pierre d'achoppement de la
possibilité de sacrifice du christ qui
donc en étant martyrs reste un symbole
pour des générations et des générations
et des millénaires
bien entendu que judas est quelqu'un qui
est un symbole tout aussi puissant et
que l'inde vers révéler d'autres retour
d'un voyage aux indes tu avais découvert
le bouddhisme et tu disais que le
bouddhisme répondait à toutes les
questions qu'on se pose est ce que tu
crois toujours ça aujourd'hui
oui ça permet de répondre à toutes les
questions
maintenant encore faut-il pouvoir les
mettre en acte parce que ce qu'on pense
est une chose se compensent n'ont qu'une
valeur sûre n'arrive pas l'appliquer à
sa vie
mais il le dit d'ailleurs ça il dit ne
crois rien que tu une expérience si tu
veux un seul mot à dire à ta fille un
seul message un seul conseil à lui
donner ce serait quoi soit toi existe
résiste et en vie parce que tant que tu
as envie tu es en vie
[Musique]
oh
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu